[Music]
an aggressive encounter between a school
police officer and a student tonight we
are seeing new video leading up to the
moments a teen was seen being restrained
by the neck at palo verde high school it
is a story we first brought you a few
weeks ago 8 news now reporter victoria
saha has been closely following the
story that you will only see on 8 news
now
it's body cam footage we obtained
because we wanted to get a clear picture
of what happened and many of you reached
out on social media asking for the same
thing this is a cell phone video that we
first showed you the student is seen
laying on the ground with the officer's
arm around her neck now this is the body
cam footage leading up to that encounter
the body cam footage sheds a new light
the officer is heard cursing at the
student numerous times as he slams her
to the ground but the student is
complying with all of his commands
there were a lot of questions into the
behavior of the officer did it fall
under ccsd policy i'll have more coming
up tonight at six brian back to you